[Music]
when we hear the word elasticity the
first picture that comes to our mind is
something like this but is this really
what elastic meets we will find that out
in this video let's take an example of a
helical spring when a force of
compression or tension is applied the
helical spring gets deformed that is it
changes in shape or size this force is
referred to as the d-forming force and
the ability of an object to regain its
original shape when the influence of
this d-forming force is removed is
called elasticity more examples of such
objects include sponge balls and rubber
bands when compressed or stretched they
get deformed but they soon returned to
their original shapes this sense
reversing deformity the object goes
through when forces applied and removed
is called elastic deformation but is
there a limit to the elasticity of an
object due elastic objects remain
elastic forever not really for instance
if a great amount of force is applied to
a spring it simply won't be able to
stretch further than a certain point but
if the force becomes excessive the
spring will get permanently deformed and
may even break if we keep increasing the
force
hence the spring does not remain elastic
forever this type of deformation where
the object is unable to attain or if it
only partially attains its original
shape once the d-forming force is
removed is called plastic deformation
now let me ask you a question suppose we
have a rubber string and a string made
of steel both of very tiny thicknesses
both are identical to each other in
terms of size and shape if we stretch
them from both the ends with equal and
opposite forces then which one will
stretch the furthest
assuming the deformation is elastic in
both the cases quite obviously the
rubber string will stretch the farthest
so steel string would barely stretch but
it is important to note that it would
indeed stretch no matter how little it
doesn't stretch as far as the rubber
string because steel applies more
resistance to the d-forming force than
the rubber does moreover as soon as the
forces removed the steel string regains
its original shape and size quicker than
the rubber string it won't allow a
d-forming force to change its dimension
as easily so which one would you say is
a more elastic seal or rubber you would
think that the obvious choice has to be
rubber but unfortunately that's
incorrect there is a general
misconception that a lot of us have
about elasticity we think that the more
the object gets stretched or compressed
the more elastic it is but elasticity is
not the same as flexibility in the
language of physics the term elastic has
a very different meaning in physics we
say a body is more elastic if it resists
more to the d-forming force and reverses
back quicker to its original shape after
the force is removed and since steel
resists more and reverses back to its
original shape quicker it's more elastic
than rubber we can mathematically define
elasticity as the ratio of stress to
strain we've teach you what stress and
strain mean in the upcoming videos but
get ready to be hooked to our next video
on Hookes law
[Music]
you